il ya de l'autre côté on entend parler
du de l'interculturalisme je trouve que
c'était aussi une manière polie de dire
multiculturalisme et à la québécoise
c'est à dire le monde multiculturalisme
a été disqualifié au québec parce que
c'est associé à trudeau où le père parce
que c'est bon c'est justement ce que je
viens de vous dire c'est de l'origine la
chose c'est fait pour des preuves
déconstruire la nation québécoise dont
on a cherché un terme ici alors il
viendrait atténuer adoucir la référence
multiculturalisme en l'adaptant la
spécialité locale
sur le fond des choses oui bien que les
biens que nuance chez ceux qui se
réfèrent l interculturalisme vraiment de
tendance dire ceux qui comme je le dis à
mon avis en fonte version locale du
multiculturalisme canadien et il ya ceux
qui disent non d'interculturalisme une
culture de référence une culture de
national d'une culture commune et donc
pour une marque différence forte mais
mon j'ai l'impression que la définition
2011 de l'interculturalisme c'est celle
qui serait proche du multiculturalisme
canadien
voilà pourquoi quand à moi à la suite de
ferments du moins bien donc je me
réclame de la culture de convergence la
culture de convergence des cultures
fondatrice dans un pays
ensuite on y adhère d'épuration se
transforme mais il ya trois mêmes
cultures de convergence qui le point de
référence la culture normatif
quand même melting-pot québécois jeunes
gens prennent pas le vocabulaire
américain je parle ni de l'assimilation
et souffre en scène une melting potes
amérique et je pense qu'elle québec a
ses propres mots pour se nommer et je
pense que dans cette culture de
convergence nous définit bien